después de días de presión mediática la
fiscalía estadounidense reveló el
documento que justifica la redada de la
casa del expresidente donald trump
hermana lago a inicios de agosto de 32
páginas 23 son ilegibles ya que se tachó
información que podría poner en riesgo
la investigación contra trump pero en
las páginas restantes se muestran las
razones que motivaron el allanamiento se
trata de 184 documentos clasificados
hallados en 15 cajas que trump entregó a
los archivos nacionales en enero pasado
después de haberlos retenido durante un
año entre estos documentos hay 67
confidenciales 92 secretos y 25 de
máximo secreto
este hallazgo de enero fue lo que
desencadenó la investigación y justificó
la redada en casa del ex presidente los
fiscales de la izquierda radical estar
manipulando con motivos políticos la ley
de documentos presidenciales bajo la que
no he hecho nada malo allanaron
ilegalmente mi casa y se llevaron cosas
que no deberían haberse llevado incluso
se metieron en mi caja fuerte algo
impensable
el documento revelado el viernes también
muestra que la defensa legal del ex
presidente intentó que la justicia no lo
investigara argumentando que se rompería
la separación constitucional de poderes
y que algunos de los archivos contenían
información confidencial sobre personas
que sirvieron como fuentes de
inteligencia a eeuu la casa blanca no
quiso pronunciarse más allá de esto
no diré nada porque no conozco los
detalles ni siquiera los quiero saber
que el departamento de justicia se
encargue de eso si la justicia encuentra
suficientes pruebas podría acusar a
trump de espionaje por el mal manejo de
estos documentos